something
on
start hey
L hey L I'm up at Corine High School
8801 if you could start a Life Squad our
way for a female staff maybe in her
M what kind
of uh head injury at this
moment I got a Life Squad coming oh my
God she feel like
she's
[Applause]
front hallway cover and back hallway am
I missing any
spots
no
so Bry just said that
he started around
theowing she can't come is there someone
else I can
call let's go to the office over here so
we're not in the hallway come here man
come on
go all
right
man all right now feel a little
dizzy back all right have a SE there
there you
go did you take anything smoke anything
drink anything took a car he said he
took a head or something in the I took a
car i a i i a take no we yeah he so
somebody give you something in the back
oh yeah okay what was it is he hurt I
think he might have hit his head he was
banging he was banging his head I think
against the
glass you get on the phone and ask to
bring an ice
pack
yeah yeah he freaked out and the P her
over there so that's what but we thought
we were two
different I think he ran over here and
just started beat his head
thisle you
cop hey was that for the
teacher for the teacher
H
yeah all right well I'll ask for another
one that come in your
area
right he said he just needs somebody to
hug it press TNS SP around little
bit I'm okay all right I'm still feel a
little you starting to freak out a
little bit I still I still feel a little
going away a little bit a little bit
okay okay okay okay okay okay calm it
down calm down calm down all right are
you going to throw up no no
okay go away
[Applause]
okay 8 55 you put me 27 and I'll be in
the vocational building with that uh
Squad room on that
side both they're both good a dream no
you're not dreaming but we got you all
right let us take care of you right got
let's take care of
you bro you're all right buddy keep keep
it chill I think I'm in a dream okay
well Hey listen I'm talking different a
little it's officer G if we can't chill
out we're going to have to go handcuffs
I don't want to do that okay I got
somebody coming check out I know you
ain't
crazy hey can one so M I'm not doing
that you what so two squads are coming
okay one's going for the teacher okay
one's coming over here can you guys just
get the one that's coming over here they
they're told to pull it vocational but
you know how that works but if you meet
them out front and just walk them in
here we're still good we definitely took
a hit of something I didn't smoke I just
hit a card a card okay what can you tell
me more about what that means yeah had
42 number it had a 42 and
I go go ahead go ahead and I asked him
can I use
it I ask him I use it let me ask you
something were you in the bathroom were
Antonio wasn't in the bathroom was
anybody else in the bathroom with you oh
it was two people who do you know them
no I don't know you don't was it was it
the bathroom outside the cafeteria hold
on stay right there okay Career Center
Career Center bathroom I got you I got
you that question for was it the career
center
bathroom people career yes or no career
bathroom yes the one by by Mel's room no
it was right there it's right there I
show you no we stay here we're stay here
back hallway back first one right there
right there in the other in the other
building yes I'm trying to help you you
got to answer my questions was it was it
was it in the back hallway right down
the hall from Miss wd's
room no no no no no okay this building
or the other building bud I got to I got
to it's
that can you the same cameras for that
what can we look at the camera I can
that's that's why I was trying to figure
out where he is thank you all right do
you want me to take the wheelchair back
with me yeah we're going to get a squad
to him here thank you thank you you're
welcome hands down keep them down here
just grab grab that right there it it
hurt cuz Hur a little bit Yeah cuz I was
running I was I ran to I was running
fast and I was glit
you're glitching do you have anything in
your in your pockets any glitches in
your pockets n
nothing okay so wa it had a 47 on it
tell me more about it you hit 42 42 on
it okay so you hit somebody's card that
had a 42
on
s
or in the building can you find out when
she can you turn radio
down this is
a could you find out when she was
okay we're trying to we're trying to
figure out what he took over here but it
sounds like he was in the
bathroom and took a cart is what he's
saying which made him freak out and then
he ran over there and I'm assuming
that's where he pars a
teacher
okay okay on okay whatever it is in you
they can make flush it out okay y can
you for I hope so too man I'll hold on
to you hold on love you just hang in
there okay I'm right with you okay
okay okay just coming us just they're
going to take yeah we want to get him
down there we want to get him down to
Children hand you okay hey bud are you
in the back are you okay to walk what's
going buddy hey you and me back there is
that okay how you doing you all right
I'm with
you hey Grandma can I get a couple
little information from you real
quick get inform from I'm offic officers
here in the school um what's your first
name do you haven't have your license on
you there's in the
car oh my
God what's a good telephone number for
you okay all right there's that back to
you I'm going to ride with him just to
make sure that he's safe going down okay
and um are you going to go down to the
hospital now with us okay we'll let them
know that you'll just go to the front ER
driveway and you park and just come into
the ER entrance and let him know that he
was transported by Squad okay J
something is wrong something is wrong
he smoked
something no he's not
okay they going to transport him to
Children Hospital come out here with me
so we don't get wound up
sorry I'm I'm going I got the door
okay
I'll be there when you
get right I get your
station I got your C at 26 we can't even
do it I'm the last one and if you drop
me back off at your
PD his car there wait from where from
Theos oh yeah they
can yeah they'll take you back yeah yeah
or just lock it and throw it in the uh
in the in the um garage there in the
kitchen yeah put it on the microwave in
the kitchen microwave in the
kitchen you
guys
points
all
right one two
three nice
appreciate
gotcha
do
that
[Music]
1o
video